mediocrity is everywhere right now and
we're all trying to find an easy way out
and we're judging ourselves let's say
there's 10 people in this room and we're
all mediocre
but i'm the best
of the mediocre people
i now think i'm great
i'm great we surround ourselves
around people that make us feel great
they tell us what we want to hear the
second we put ourselves amongst the
uncommon people
we don't like that feeling that
challenge and feeling that of that
person is waking up at 3 30 in the
morning hey push we're going for a run
we don't like that challenge we like
that person who says hey you know what
man i don't feel good today man and they
say oh it's okay brother we'll take a
day off maybe we'll get a pizza and game
we like that we we love that feeling why
because you understand man we're good
bro we don't want
like this hey man no bro get your
man stop being a punk
we don't want that in our lives we don't
want that person who's constantly
challenging our weaknesses
we want that process constantly you know
making us feel nice and good and secure
in ours that's the mediocrity of life
we want to be the best amongst the
average people people wonder how do you
stay
hungry all the time
because after i accomplish something i
don't sit back like a lot of guys who
graduate buds graduate this graduate
that they get comfortable they wonder
why i'm getting weak man i don't know
i've lost my edge what's going on
because once you hit the top of the
mountain guess what happened
i'm good
i'm good so you wonder why you're
falling down now because once you're top
of the mountain you gotta build another
one that's mediocrity there's a lot of
people in mediocrity who have a nice
resume
but they're one-timers man they hit they
hit a one-time deal they busted it open
got a lot of money
but they're good
you're a mediocre now man
what are you doing today tomorrow the
next day that's why i'm listening to
theorists
i don't listen all that
i listen to who's like this man
what's wrong man tired dude why are you
tired because tomorrow
i gotta do the
again man whatever it is that made me
nauseous and sick to my stomach it made
me hurt
there's no ending
and that's the person i listen to that's
the person who's gained knowledge you
gain knowledge through suffering
and on the other end of suffering
is a world that very few
very few have ever seen it's a beautiful
world because that's where you find
yourself
you don't find yourself in over here
you find yourself on the other end like
the 100 mile race i was on i ran it for
24 hours
i found myself
on the other end of that race that 19
hours i found wow there's a whole nother
world out here that never even saw the
world is in your mind
and that's what all that mediocrity is
about mediocre is contagious if you are
the most ambitious person that you know
you are going to play small for life
look around at your friends your family
the people that you hang out with what
do they want out of life if you're the
one always pushing them and no one's
pushing you guess what happens you don't
get the push that you need and you stay
in mediocrity being the best in a group
of unambitious people so i just came
back from an event in florida that i was
doing a keynote at and at the end i
challenged an entrepreneur who showed up
to make some changes on his youtube
channel we met over dinner i helped him
with his youtube channel it was him and
his business partner sitting there and i
said by tomorrow here's what i want you
to do i want you to go in and make sure
you have these things updated and he
said yes i'll do it i said it's
important to do it by tomorrow because
i'm still here i'm still here in the
morning if you need anything you can ask
me face-to-face while i'm still here
before i fly home to toronto yes i'll do
it next morning comes around
we show up in a meeting i got a meet-up
happening we got i don't know 30 people
who showed up to to meet with me
and i see him out of the corner of my
eye sitting at the back of the room and
i say hey did you do the thing that i
told you to do
i said no i didn't do it
i said why what happened i said well we
we were doing lots of other stuff it's
been a full day you know we had this
entire day of of speaking and meeting
people and then so much information went
home we were doing all this kind of work
okay great but what about the promise
that you made to me to do it and then
his business partner chimes in and said
you know it's actually my fault i told
him evan's probably not going to notice
he's not going to remember don't worry
about it we'll take care of it when we
all fly back home
and so i told him
don't let your business partners low
standards prevent you from moving
forward on the things that you said you
were going to do
staying committed to the thing that you
say you're going to do your word to
yourself is the whole game forget about
what you just say to other people what
do you do for yourself because we're
often looking for no's we're often
looking for somebody else to give us a
break right he's been working hard and
and he is i know him and i know his
business partner and these guys are not
slackers they're not slackers and and i
was poking a little bit at his business
partner saying his low expectations his
low standards but in this situation it
was true
the entrepreneur that i was speaking to
said he was going to do this thing by
tomorrow morning before he came and went
to my event he would do it
and his business partner says he's not
going to remember don't worry we've
worked too hard already let it go we'll
do it when we get home and they would do
it when they got home i know they would
he's looking for the reason not to do it
when you say you want to hit the gym
when you say you want to hit these
business goals when you say you want to
have this outcome and be proud of the
effort that you put in every day when
you say that you're going to do
something
there will be moments where you want to
let yourself up the hook will you say i
work so hard or i'm so tired or i
deserve a break right this is the
language you use to yourself and so when
that happens you're looking for
affirmations from the people around you
and if you are the most ambitious person
in your friend group if you are the most
ambitious person what's gonna happen
they're gonna say you already worked so
hard anyway what are you talking about
yes of course give yourself the break
and it's the exact answer that you're
looking for because you want to give
yourself a break
now if you're proud of your effort maybe
you should take a break but it's not
because somebody with lower standards
gave you the pass
it's because you're proud of the effort
that you put in and so this is where it
gets really dangerous when you are the
most successful the most ambitious
person from the people around you
they're always going to give you a
reason to play smaller
you can't accept it you have to push
through you need to change your
environment i'm going to give you three
ways to do it step number one is collect
good people
i like to say i'm in the business of
collecting good people you want to
collect good somebody that you meet
on the on the street at an event online
collect them find ways to stay in touch
follow them on instagram and on youtube
and comment on their stuff tell them
sometimes this gets super awkward i've
told people i really like you i really
love your style i really like everything
you're doing
i just want to stay in touch
and maybe that means you're just dming
them when you have questions maybe that
means you're setting something formal up
or you're having a coffee meeting every
month to connect maybe that means you're
asking them you know business questions
whenever you have them there's a lot of
different ways that the relationship can
take shape and this is where a lot of
people fall down is you expect to have
the answer in your head and when you
don't know what the relationship will
look like you don't go for it because
you don't know what to present you don't
know what the pitch you don't know what
to say and so you say nothing and that's
the worst case scenario don't do that
tell somebody i love your vibe i love
the energy how do we stay in touch
and then whatever flows
flows you have to be in the business of
collecting good people you want good
people around you not just for your team
but people who are your peers people who
can be your mentors because when you get
that situation when you say i promised
myself that i would do this tomorrow i
promised myself that before tomorrow
morning this would happen the people
around you are saying dude what are you
doing let's go
not oh you work so hard you deserve a
break no let's go you promised yourself
you would do it come on
they pull you up to be the best version
of you step number two is get
aspirational mentors i love being around
people who've done a lot more than me
this is actually my default
i don't really have
people in my life who push me to be
better i don't have too many people
around me say evan you really suck at
this let's go get better get better get
better i get most of mine from
aspirational mentors from from steve
jobs and ap genini and howard schultz
and kanye west the videos that i put up
every single day on my channel
so i had a buddy of mine say i really
love it when you do a david goggins
video or another one yesterday i said i
really love it when you do kobe bryant
great if you know that kobe inspires you
or david inspires you then surround
yourself with him
right watch their youtube videos watch
their interviews have a google alert
that comes at any time it says kobe
bryant interview or david goggins
interview you get a notification listen
to their podcast if they have one read
their book listen to their audios write
as much as possible be around that
because the more you are around that
they're training you to think like they
think they're pulling you up to their
level even if you never meet them
that's what i try to do with my channel
every day is i need it selfishly for
myself there's people that i surround
myself with daily i want elon musk and
steve jobs and oprah winfrey and these
people pulling me up to make me better
so get yourself some aspirational
mentors the people that you look up to
and say man i wish you could be like
them you can you just have to think like
that and the way to think like them and
act like they have the mindset of them
is to be around them more often and step
number three is have play bigger
triggers i like having triggers in my
environment that force me to remind
myself of who i am of who i would like
to be of what i'm becoming so you can
have the greatest day of all time maybe
you watch this video and you're fired up
you get motivated say yes i'm gonna go
and do some work awesome you're gonna
wake up tomorrow and be the person who
used to be again
you wake up tomorrow and it's a new day
every day is a new day and so you might
remember to do something but chances are
you may not and so that's why having
played bigger triggers in your
environment you set them up once and it
reminds you to go off and play a bigger
game so my office there's a bunch of
play bigger triggers here right there's
there's mentors of mine including my
parents who are looking at me every time
i walk into here there's there's the
awards down here which remind me of what
i do that that a million people have
subscribed to my channel now where to
it's a crazy number that when i'm coming
to make a video
lots of people are watching it i have my
neck braces down there to remind myself
of when i broke my neck it kept going on
my tour i've got my doritos here to
remind myself that i'm stronger than
these doritos damn the doritos these
things are stronger than me no all i
want to do is eat this bag every single
day and standing here is a reminder of
how awesome i am at least that's what
i'm telling myself right they're all
play bigger triggers so what's in your
physical environment what's the
background on your cell phone what's the
background on your desktop how can you
set up your environment once just with
some thoughtful thinking once
but then every time you walk into it it
lifts you up also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video i've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the lessons
learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business i'll see you there
people are saying man you cuss all the
time why
well
i hate to say it the best way for me to
get how i feel across
i can't sit here and say you know what
yeah i went through hell weekend man it
was it was really hard
no that
takes your damn soul rips it inside out
and then they say
now we're going to
start
it
it allows me to express
where i was at at a point of my life
if i don't give you all of me why the
hell am i here
why how will you learn from me
people take so much offense to me
you will never learn from people if we
always tap dance around the truth oh god
i love that we tap dance around the
truth by
finding the right word so i don't hurt
you because you have thin skin
no
tighten up people it's okay trust me
it's okay you might be called [ __ ] one
day
it's okay
you might be called some jewish word or
some
or gay word it's okay
let them call you that what are you
going to do now they don't own your life
how are you going to control that now
how are you going to flip it upside down
and say roger that
now i'm going to harness it
and you'll read about me years from now
how that's the question how are you
going to do that
thicken your skin become more of a human
being don't be afraid of the reflection
in the mirror because that's all you can
be afraid of
once you overcome the reflection in the
mirror
you've done it
i love that man you once said that if
you were growing up in this generation
that you would have a field day because
you would take their souls what did you
mean by that the younger generation
quits
not everybody
so i gotta i gotta put that people get
their butt hurt so not everybody
most of this generation quits the second
they get
talked to
you did this wrong you did this wrong or
or they get yelled at it's so easy to
just you know to be great nowadays
because everybody else is most people
are weak
this this is a softened generation so if
you have any mental toughness
any any ability if you have any fraction
of self-discipline
the ability to
not want to do it but still do it people
have a hard thing to understand i hate
to run
and and what makes me so crazy
it doesn't need more is people
why do you run if you hate it what are
you talking about
i don't want to take showers and eat
either i hate that too
the whole that's a life man
that and and
it wasn't until i changed that mentality
that i became somebody
i hated going to school so guess what i
was dumb
that's what
one plus one is two
but if you can get through
to doing things that you hate to do
on the other side is greatness
that's what people understand
by me running i am callous in my mind
i'm not training for a race
i'm training for life
i'm training for the time when i get
that two o'clock in the morning call
that my mom is dead or something happens
tragic in life
i don't fall apart
i'm training my mind and my body my
spirit so it's all one so i can handle
what life is gonna throw at me because
the life i've lived
it throws a whole bunch at you and if
you're not physically immensely prepared
for that
you're just gonna crumble and you're
good for nobody
talk to me about what it takes to be on
one side of a door in iraq or anywhere
knowing on the other side of the door
people who are not afraid of you
they're ready for you to come in and you
still have and they have guns and you
still have to breach that door
that's that's a great question it
that's
a very scary situation when you are on
one side of the door
and your mind is racing because on the
other side of that door
it could be no one
it could be four guys with four ak-47s
that
that door you're about to open could be
booby-trapped so once you open it boom
your legs are gone
so
there's a thousand things you think
about when you're the first guy second
guy third guy getting ready to go in a
room and flooding and that's why i talk
about the warrior mentality and that's
why so many people
are lost when i start talking
you have
the right
you're lucky
that you don't have to think like
warriors think you're very privileged i
chose this world to be a warrior now and
i would choose it again if i came back
to this world
but the mentality of a warrior is very
different than normal mentality
you must be that person on that door oh
get ready to open it thinking to
yourself
if i die
so be it
the only way you can go in that door is
knowing there's a great chance you're
going to die like being a seal you train
with live ammo
you jump on an airplane every everything
you do
you could die
so to be a warrior why people don't
understand me i'm glad you don't
understand me merry christmas good on
you because being a warrior takes a
whole different mindset
a whole different mindset to know that
there's a great chance i may not be in
him though like i was in for 21 years
i'm lucky
i'm very lucky that i'm alive able to
talk to you able to still run but when
you sign up on that dialogue to be upset
like a seal your mentality changes
i may not live
you gotta accept that
and that's the mentality you have
and that's what makes you a warrior if
you're scared to die
you're a bad warrior
and so what do you use to
push through is that is that a goggins
moment is that uh finding the darkness
i'm going through hell i'll become the
devil if i have to like what what is
that moment what are you pulling up
inside i'm pulling up a lot of the
the dark side of me but i'm also
looking at the guys to my left and to my
right
realizing that um we're here together
man
and i have to uh
i have to be strong for them and they
got to be strong for me
a lot of people either you like me or
don't even in the seal teams
but when you get to that door or you get
on that mission or you're getting an op
all that out the door man
you know
you you do it honestly i mean people say
all the time in these movies
you you really out there fighting for
that guy beside you
and you can't be a coward
because you know what this i look at
everything i do now in life and this
sums it up
i hated jumping out of airplanes
i hated shooting guns
i hated the job as a navy seal
but i did it because i wanted to
change myself
everything i do i'm not really
comfortable doing
but if you choose to go that route to go
be a navy seal
you might as well go be the hardest in
the world
because if you're choosing to do
something you have two routes you can go
there and be a little a little weak
person and get through barely and that's
your reputation
or you can go through
the hardest guy you can possibly be
natural reputation so my whole thing is
if you're going to choose to open that
door in iraq or afghanistan open them go
in hard
because they're going to remember you
by slowly opening it and peeking in
so if you're going to open it and you
made the mind open it don't crack it
open open the door go in that's with
life
if you're choosing to do if you're
choosing to do something attack it
because they're going to remember you
as not attacking it so i want to be
remembered you can hate me but there's
one thing you can't say about me
i didn't attack it
so that's the mentality you have if
you're gonna do something you might as
well attack it because you could do it
anyway right
do you use that in civilian life like do
you still
employ the i'm gonna attack it i'm going
to take their souls like how does that
play out in a non-um
combat
zone it still works for me in in life as
far as attacking things
because uh no matter what i want to you
know no matter what avenue i choose i
want to be the very best
and the very best may not be
i'm number one
the very best is did i leave everything
inside of me
out there
so attacking is not like oh i want to
win this or win that or be the best
the best is i'm i'm running against
myself and everything i do
and and that's and that's what i attack
i attack myself i'm always questioning
myself i'm always holding myself
accountable so many people before i give
them a workout plan they're talking
about recovery everybody everybody that
hears me speak
they want to go straight to recovery
work out first
work out first before you talk to me
about recovery how to recover yeah
work out first we are always looking for
like whenever i talk to people people
take my words
and they and they and they put it in a
way to where
they want to feel comfortable this guy
you know they they they want to put you
in a box
they want to put a title on you
no you're putting a title on me to make
yourself feel better about yourself
if you read this book of mine and you
see where i came from this person was
this this person was not built
this this person was not made by god
this person sorry this person was built
i made this person
i made this person by diving into the
insecurities that life gave me because
now they're yours they're yours to own
if you're not smart
call yourself dumb
it's okay
because you are
but take that knowledge you put yourself
down if you're fat car yourself fat i
used to be 300 pounds
we we want to talk so soft to ourselves
we're looking for that recovery day
and that recovery day is everything in
your life
everything in your life is a recovery
day we're looking for it it's not coming
it's not coming
get over that recovery day
and that's the mentality i took with me
and what happened through that process
was all the frivolous things of life
started to float away i have to tell
people lies so they would like me
because i was so insecure
when you start to build yourself up
and start to have the one thing that we
don't have is confidence yeah real
authentic confidence from hard work
everything else goes away you no longer
look
to other people for yourself validation
right
you now know
i walk in the room now and i know that
hours and years and decades
i put into david goggins
that's something it's not on the wall
it's not a trophy on the wall it's not a
male around your neck
it is actually a feeling in your heart
and people why don't you ever smile
i don't have to
yeah i do have a stoic look at my face
i'm a very focused person but the thing
i have in my soul and my heart
that's why i need to smile
i don't need to smile i don't need you
to look at me and say oh my god you look
happy because half of us aren't happy
we're giving you something that we think
you want to see
i don't do that anymore
i don't care how you perceive david
goggins because through my journey i
figured out the one piece i was missing
i thought it was cars i thought it was
women i thought it was i thought it was
my i thought was everything the one
piece i was missing was me having the
courage to face myself
one big thing is the accountability
mirror
you have to start with yourself
so what happened in my life
was we start to get i call it like the
rucksack a rucksack is a pack that you
carry in the military and you put all
your stuff in it your radios your food
your water all that stuff you have to
carry the military that's your rucksack
it's a backpack pretty much
as you're growing up
we all have a backpack most of ours
hopefully is empty
you know and what we put in it is all
the crap we go through in life
that's what is in the backpack for the
civilians
and we carry it around with us
so what you have to start doing is
realizing that no matter where you're at
in life
i got called [ __ ] a lot my dad abused
me you know learning disability stutters
immaturity insecurities self-doubt so
much crap on top of me so much stuff i
lied a lot to create friends so people
so much stuff was in my backpack
no one's coming back to help me
so it starts with that person in that
mirror
you have to realize you are on your own
now and whatever else you believe in i
don't care what you believe in but
on earth it's a very lonely journey
it starts with the accountability mirror
of looking at saying hey my dad who beat
the hell i mean he's not coming back all
these things are coming back i have to
face myself
and you have to own
all those things that people may have
done to you now it's yours
you got to own it it's yours now to fix
the problems that people did to you it
makes no sense it's not fair
i get it but if you live in that what
was me mentality of guess what
my dad did this to me my mom just did to
me people who bullied did this to me
you're gonna always live right there
you have to figure out ways to move
forward because you're not coming back
it starts with the mirror i call it the
accountability mirror in the book my
biggest advice to give everybody in the
world
it's like i say we live in an external
world
everything is is you got to see it touch
it it's external
if you can for
the rest of your life live inside of
yourself
stop listening to people who are calling
you fat gay transsexual [ __ ]
everything that is makes no sense all
these insecure people putting their
insecurities on you you got to flush it
out
you got to just be whoever the hell god
or whatever the hell you believe in if
you believe in nothing but yourself i
don't care what it is
you got to take everything and throw it
away
you have to believe in one thing and
that is yourself
and and i'm not saying don't believe in
god or what you believe in but right now
for you to find greatness in yourself
you're not going to find it by looking
in a book
or by even hearing me i may give you the
spark
but you've got to go inside yourself to
find it and that means you got to be
quiet shut up go in a room
stop talking search
your soul search your mind search your
abilities and you'll find it
but if you're not looking for it
you won't find it
so you got to go start your journey and
the journey starts with you finding why
the hell am i here on this planet earth
why am i here
if you don't know that you will live the
rest of your life searching
always asking the question why
with your learning disability with your
dad beating you
screaming at you emotionally challenging
your mind with uh the racism you dealt
with with um
the different struggles you felt with
bullies what was the
hardest obstacle to overcome from
up until about 15 16. the hardest
obstacle was myself
i started realizing more and more and
more
that all these people were gone
what was haunting me was me
i can't control my dad
i can't control the people calling me
[ __ ] i can't control all these things
but they were things that kept me down
it started to become my reality
my reality was what they made it out to
be
and i became all
the most important conversation you'll
ever have with your life you know in
your life is when you have yourself
and my conversation was absolutely
horrifying what were you saying to
yourself
i'm dumb
i'm nobody my dad i mean my dad was
great in mental warfare
a drunk insecure man
will make everybody around him feel like
hell
yeah because he wants to give you no
power
and that's why he was so
mean to my mom and myself and my brother
because he didn't want anybody to get
above him
he want to keep you down low so when
you're growing up with all this stuff
all this hate it it wasn't the beatings
i could hit the beatings all day it was
a mental torture
so when at a young age your your parents
put a dialogue in you of confidence
or you're nobody
so that voice in my head was i'm a loser
and then it was confirmed
when i got in school and in third grade
i was falling behind they want to put me
in a special school yeah you know with
kids you can't learn right
then it was confirmed what you know what
my dad was saying so that confirmed it
then i started cheating so i started
realizing you know what i'm taking the
easy way out again yeah and it starts
snowballing from there now now the kids
are calling me [ __ ]
but it wasn't all the kids so what
happens is
you start to get this picture that
everybody hates you
because your reality becomes so
so big
that you don't
i mean you can't see the clear picture
it might have been three or four that's
it doing it over and over right but it
was the whole town yeah everybody hated
me so
the world hates me that's right yeah and
that's when they that's when it became
toxic
and that is where i became my worst
enemy my junior year in high school
and i fell back a lot i felt back in
this whole of life the second you think
that you've overcome it you climbed
everest you're on that last hold
and life will say not today
and it'll push you down
and my junior year in high school i uh
missed a whole bunch of school
was lining my mom had like a one point
something gpa i was just jacked up i
mean it was i was in one one of the
worst spots in my life
and my mom was going through a lot too
and she didn't have time to sit back and
baby me
and it was me against me and my pants
down to my knees i was just i was
not whatever was going on i was in a bad
shape so i went to the bathroom and i
had this weird haircut because i wanted
attention
i was an attention getter i went to all
white school pretty much
um some of the kids liked me a lot of
them didn't like me whatever i was
looking for something so i was dressed
differently crazy haircuts and i went to
the mirror
and
the reflection in it revealed
a lot of bad things
a lot of things that i was hiding behind
the saggy pants and i'm looking at
myself in the mirror going like god dawg
dude you gotta you are something else
man like you have created a character i
want to be the cool guy table
and whatever i could do to to get
attention i did it wasn't me
it wasn't who i was inside but i was
scared for anybody to know who i was
inside
so in that accountability mirror i call
it i got real myself
i said
you have a third grade reading level
which is hard to admit when you're a
junior in high school that you copied on
every single thing you did because
of fear they're gonna put me in a
special school we all know what special
means i only have a title on myself the
rest of my life
and being cool you don't have a title on
yourself so i started cheating
i was dumb and people say oh you know
you have learning disability
out of learning disability i realized i
was lazy
so
i called myself out there
i called myself out every which way
possible i didn't call myself i was just
honest
i was honest look at yourself man
look at yourself and it was that day
in a couple of days after that i just
got real with myself and every day i
came home i called the accountability
mirror what am i going to do today to
change what i see in this mirror
what am i going to do today and a lot of
it was i stopped sitting with the cool
guys
i actually took my shirt and went to
school looking like hey man this is how
i'm going to look if you don't like it
so be it i had to really wear this this
this layer of skin
i had to develop a really callous skin
on me to take whatever you're going to
call me you're going to call me whatever
i'm going to be you know i want a geek
but whoever i am you're going to see me
you're going to see me for who i am
because i need to change who i'm not
and that accountability just became raw
and i became fat over the years because
i fell back in the hole i called myself
fat because i was fat and people don't
want to do that
they want to say oh don't call yourself
fat
don't call yourself dumb if you're not
real and raw with who you are
nothing's going to change in this nice
new world that we live in we want to
hear you're just a little big no man you
might be fat
and it's okay to hear that from yourself
infamous so that's where it started at
and it's raw it gets ugly sometimes with
me in that mirror
but i'm also proud of myself to be able
to tell myself that and then fix what's
in that mirror seal training became
pretty hard and a lot of guys weren't
getting through it
so they designed a seal pep prep program
like a boot camp for the boot camp
that's right yeah and it was two months
in my last two years before i retired
from the military they sent me there to
train these kids wow to get ready for 15
19 20 years young kids
so when they get to navy seal training
man they were physical studs
they were running swimming i mean they
were they were hybrids wow
but they get the buds
and the same amount of people would quit
why is that
this is why
we were training bigger stronger faster
quitters
hmm
it's not about not the mind that's right
we weren't diving into the sewer
everybody's got a story
we don't share it on social media
we share our nice life on social media
we have we all have a dungeon i'm just
willing to talk about mine yeah most of
us don't really talk about it i want to
talk about my dungeon
i wasn't getting into the dungeon of
these guys minds
i wasn't building that so-called mental
toughness mental toughness isn't
something that you
sample
it's something that you live in every
day
so when something hard would happen to
these kids like in hell week
it would draw on something that made
them very insecure
and they look for comfort
whenever hardness comes and you don't
know what it is it may be different for
you than this for me but you go back to
your insecurities
and then when you go back to the
insecurities you then look for comfort
within those insecurities
and we all look for that cookie that
your mom used to give you when you were
sad yeah when you were sick we look for
our wife or our husband we look for
comfort
it's in those moments
you must retrain your mind
to think differently in hell
i wasn't training them to do that
why weren't you training i wasn't
training myself yet because at that time
i was doing what i was told
these guys need to meet a standard
physical standard a physical standard
the physical standard is not what they
need to meet
it's a mental standard you must meet in
life we live in a world now
that's so kind we we find the kind way
around everything
like if you don't look good
i have to find a kind way of saying i
don't like your shirt right that's not
the approach if that's the approach
you're looking for that book is not for
you
can't hurt me is not for you the
approach you have to take at least i
took you take whatever approach you want
the conversation had to be a real honest
conversation in the accountability
mirror guess what
i was fat
don't find a kind word to say that you
know what i've gained some weight no
you're fat
when i couldn't read
not like hey you know even learn
disability no i cannot read i have a
fourth grade reading level i'm
struggling
and sometimes i call myself stupid not
in a way to put myself down so don't
take it like my god those are so
horrific yeah the hurtful
dishonest
the conversation has to become an honest
conversation of where you're at mentally
where am i mentally i look like
i feel like
i'm not this i'm i'm falling behind in
school i'm lazy
my house is a mess
you have to look at what it is and call
it what it is don't find words to make
yourself feel better because that's what
so we hang around people
that make us feel better that tell us
what we want to hear not what we need to
hear
and so we stay away from those people
and we stay away from those people like
our internal dialogue becomes that kind
it's okay
it's not okay
so that's where it starts it starts with
that accountability of it's not okay
anymore
this can no longer be okay
and calling yourself out for exactly
what you are
and exactly how you need to fix it i
never thought in my wildest dreams
i could be a navy seal
it's until you opened your mind
open-mindedness creates that we all shut
down our mind like for instance
when i broke the pull-up record
everybody around me who heard the
pull-up record was four thousand and
twenty pull-ups
that's the first thing they did oh my
god
four thousand and twenty-four hours or
yeah it's four thousand twenty pull-ups
in 24-hour period yeah yeah the first
thing i did versus closing my mind
you're like oh my god that's crazy
i went and got a penny okay how many is
that every minute exactly every hour
every second instead of taking life and
making out to be
this grandiose thing start breaking it
down
start breaking it down and
most of us we live in a box
and we don't want to go outside that box
at all ever
outside that box is all these
possibilities of life
what we do is we shackle our mind we are
a prisoner in our own mind that this is
all i can do this is all i'm good at
and we we we take away the possibilities
of you could be this you could be that
yeah you could be all these things
and i never thought that 300 pounds i
could be negative wow so if my mind was
shackled
me and you would never meet
there'd be no book right there'd be no
book right there'd be nothing
so
what people understand is that they live
for themselves not knowing that you have
the power within yourself to change
millions of lives yeah by facing life by
facing yourself
and through that
i i would die never knowing
that i had the power to change millions
of lives it will haunt me the most if
you ask me what haunts you the most
what helps me most is that if i would
have died at 300 pounds let's say i was
75 years old
i got to heaven and god has a chart like
that on everybody's life
god knows all let's say that
i don't care what you believe in doesn't
matter i'm not judging anybody let's say
my thing is god you get to heaven i'm
300 pounds i sit down i was a cockroach
terminated my whole life
and we're sitting down just like this
you're god and i'm david
and he gives me that chart
and he says look at this
now look at this chart and on the chart
it has
all these different things
but my names on it but these things
aren't me
i was going to change the world i was
going to i was going to set records i
was going to be a navy seal i could be
all these things in the military that i
accomplished you're gonna get the vfw
award you could be honored here honored
there
and i'm like god i was this isn't me
like it says david goggins
i was an eco-lab guy i pray for
cockroaches and i'm 300 pounds i said
here i'm 185.
it says here i got a
a bachelor's and a master's it says all
these things
and god goes no
that's who you were supposed to be wow
my biggest fear in life
is if there is a final resting place in
this world
and there's a final judgment
and you talk to something much bigger
than you
i don't want to sit down have a
conversation with someone
with something that says you're in
heaven
this is what you should have been on
earth
and
are you really in heaven now are you in
hell
thinking about how much i left on a
table for fear
for not willing to go over the wall and
over the next wall and over the next
wall so in my mind i believe that
and god knows all
at least i believe that
i want
god to be up there right now as we're
speaking
writing stuff down saying my god he
exceeded even my expectations
that's how i live my life i now know
that there is no cap
on the human mind
there's no cap
we cap it ourselves
the world is so fast-paced the world is
so noisy so my conversation now a lot of
times is my god slow down
the world can take you here here
be here be there be everywhere and i
lose myself sometimes
so i catch myself in the airport i catch
myself in the plane when i'm writing
stuff down okay remember this remember
that i'm not going hey hang on a second
guys what got you here this isn't what
got you here slow down
go back to the quiet place of that dirty
mirror in that seven dollar a month
place you used to live in
that's where you grew
you so i so that's what i'm constantly
reminding myself go back to your roots
i'm not saying go back to hell
but i'm saying don't forget where you
come from as you start to explode out of
the gate when you become someone
my conversation is
do not forget your roots
do not forget your roots don't let this
become so big that you lose yourself
amongst the noise go back to the
quietness of what made you successful i
believe that most human beings are only
living at about 40
of their capability
so
the mine has a governor like a car
if you're driving a car
and the car has a governor on it the car
may say 130 miles an hour but the
governor set for 91.
once that governor sets in you get to 91
that car starts doing this the car wants
to go the car wants to go but that
factory said uh-uh we're not going past
91. we have a factory a nice governor in
our brain and it's a survival mechanism
it protects us from pain and suffering
the second we feel that our mind says oh
no this isn't fun
we should back off we should sit down
find something more comfortable and
there's something about the mind the
mind has the tactical advantage over you
at all times
at all times of your life
the mind has a tactical advantage over
you why is that
it knows what you're afraid of it knows
your insecurities it knows your deep
dark lies
and it starts to push you away from that
it pushes you in a direction that is
comfortable
the mind
controls everything so what i realized
was that when i was growing up and i was
300 pounds and i got all fat and i got
all insecure
i realized that my mind
kept taking me in this direction when
things got uncomfortable for me when i
was facing my insecurities i was facing
my fears my mind said oh no we have the
tactical advantage we need to get you
separate you from this feeling this
feeling over your life's all about
feelings we want the happy feeling we
don't want that feeling of this sucks
why am i here and you don't have any
so you can't answer those questions so
you leave
i started realizing that if in that
moment
you can answer those
questions
and you are now in charge of your brain
versus your brain ruling you
that's where all that stuff comes from
so so the 40 rule is all of that you get
to 40
your brain says we're done let's roll
man this is starting to get painful this
is uncomfortable so you sit down
you have to figure out ways and
everybody's different that's how the
book kind of talks about like we all
have these things about you know
five steps to this and four steps to
this it's a lot more than that that's
all [ __ ] it's it's a practice that
you have to it's a habit
so if you know that at 40 i'm still you
know i'm feeling pain
at 40 i'm feeling pain that's where the
40 rule kicks in
now it starts okay i'm feeling pain my
mind's saying all this to me is saying
get out of here run flee the
fight-or-flight kicks in okay we're done
we're not good enough it starts telling
you all these things you start to
believe it because the mind controls all
this is the time where you have to gain
control back of your mind
it's okay let me see if i can go 45
and once you start giving yourself more
and more hope and start realizing okay
the mind starts to be okay what are you
doing we're supposed to be going right
and you're going left
you start then controlling your mind
start finding more in you know in
yourself and then it goes from 40 to a
lot further than that but that's the
start of it though get to get to the
spot where your mind is saying stop
wherever that is you gotta get there
first and then that's when that starts
to work for you you gotta control
yourself in that moment what was the
greatest lesson your mom taught you
growing up
honestly the greatest lesson she ever
taught me is a lesson that she
she doesn't know how much she taught me
because
she wasn't much in the teaching mode
my dad took her soul but what i did as a
young kid
is i observed
everybody
i wasn't really smart in the books yeah
but i was real smart when it came to
life yeah and i was able to sit back and
watch her mistakes i was able to see
how she struggled through life
and how i don't want to struggle through
life and i was able to see
she never picked me up the biggest thing
she did for me and this is honest to god
truth and she doesn't even know she did
it
when i would bust my ass and i would
fail yeah when i was at the bottom of
the sewer she never picked me up
she never gave me that cookie and said
hey son you know it's gonna be okay
so never she didn't have time for that
and sometimes she gets upset when i talk
about my past because it pains her out
to be
not the best mom
if i had any kind of mom in that kind of
environment
i would have never made it
because
she forced me for every reason
she forced me
to you better figure this out or you're
going to be a statistic wow
and this is something that she didn't
sit down to tell me
i realized this this is the world that
is in front of me
and what most people do is they see this
world
and they look at it as an excuse to get
out of it
yeah
i started looking at it
as
this is the ultimate training ground for
the rest of my life
[Music]
i have all these valuable lessons
because if you look out in the world
right now today it's not a nice place
but i'm very prepared for it yeah you
are i'm prepared for it i'm prepared for
all the failure coming my way
i'm prepared for everything my way and
that's the biggest lesson that she
taught me by not teaching me
by never saying it's gonna be okay
matter of fact she told me the exact
opposite life sucks
when you really sit back at your life
and you are in that dark room
and you're looking at where you started
from and you tell yourself
ah man my mom is this way my stupid step
dad got murdered my dad beat
me
i can't read and write to say my soul
i've lied about it to everybody i've
cheated on all these tests
my god man
and then you put a goal
in your mind
how are you going to feel man when you
accomplish this goal coming from that
a lot of people start from a good
starting point they have a good
foundation what if you can surpass all
of these
we have everybody who was way up here
started up here and you had you started
with no legs you had to grow legs to
even start walking and then crawling and
then running and then you start passing
people and all that's given to them
i had to use all this negative
that was making me weak and horrible as
a person
i had to use this as the power that now
fueled me how to flip it on his head and
say hold up
this might be exactly what i need
the darkness
is exactly what i need it's how you look
at your situation
and i was looking at it all
in the book you tell people to make a
list
of everything working against them every
real valid excuse right why do you have
them do that
there's a lot of power in that list
so
in that list of
who you are what makes you
all these other things it goes back to
once again
accepting
you have to first accept it before you
can fix it
a lot of people walk around oh man i'm
good
i'm good
no you're not
you have to accept what you're not
you have to and people don't want to do
that
that's the only way you can fix it
you have to accept it first before you
can go on the journey
a lot of folks never even start the
journey man
they never start to join because they
live in this fake life
that who they want to be
they act like they are but they're not
because they haven't fixed all this
stuff yet
you got to fix this first before we can
start our journey in life so that's why
i haven't make this list you fix these
problems now your journey can begin
because you no longer care about how
people are judging you
when you care more about how someone's
judging you you're going to stay right
there
there's no forward momentum
so that's the thing about that list when
i picked up your book the thing i loved
about it is the amount of effort that
you've been through to give us i'm sure
this was suffering too like writing this
book the amount of effort that you've
been through to actually give us
detail right on your life we all have
different things in our life that have
scarred us
we want to act like those scars don't
exist so those scars like you know if
you go out and you get cut that scar is
going to be there on your arm you can go
down and look at that cut and say oh or
or that scar and say oh that happened
from
you know i was in the kitchen or what
happened
we have the same thing in our brain
i have all these scars on my brain from
growing up
from you know
being abused from suffering through life
from having a learning disability from
stuttering from having just a really bad
childhood and so all those memories i
had to cut open that scar
and go into it and that was a hard
process for me to do not only was that a
hard process for me to do for me to have
the courage to share that with people
you know because i'm the so-called
toughest man on the planet so they think
so for me to break open that shell and
tell people hey
that wasn't always me
you know it's it's hard to do you know
it's hard to do so it was a tough
process throughout this journey i
started becoming this new person i
started creating this new person people
started seeing me
as this
amazing superhero
in the back of my mind i knew the real
story and i was like man one day you
have to really share it i'm like man but
do you have the courage
you know like it's great to live right
here i've established this people think
you're great just stay here don't go
back let's not go back but the only way
you can help people out
is let them know that this is possible
so i had to go back and say
this is where i come from yeah and where
i come from is hell a lot of people can
live with themselves look in the mirror
and say i'm okay with being afraid
i'm okay with going on this easy highway
over here the easy highway has all these
signs directions how to get somewhere
and you have to first be uncomfortable
with how you feel about yourself with
that voice that a lot of us like to run
away from we all have it
we all have that voice to say hey man
you know you're you're kind of wimping
out right now you're kind of being a
little punk right now but a lot of us
say okay that's okay
it's okay to tell these little white
lies to ourselves so we first have to
face the real you
the real me is david goggins the real me
is a guy looking at you right now saying
i don't want to be on this show right
now because i used to stutter as a kid
and i'm afraid of that i'm afraid that
here in a second i'm going to start
stammering and stuttering the whole
world is going to know that i have all
these issues
but that's when i see right now okay
goggins you got to go on this show
that's goggins
goggins is saying okay david goggins
you're a punk life made you this way we
can't live like this we can't live in
fear we can't live in judgment
we can't be afraid of what
people right now are looking at me
saying about me we cannot be afraid of
that
that's goggins
god is saying for all of you who don't
like me who don't want to and that
person then comes in
but you have to be david goggins and say
man i'm afraid of this i'm
here life made me this way here
i stutter i i have these issues with
with uh reading and writing and and i'm
i'm fat and i'm insecure
you have to face that in that dark room
and that dark room is who you are
but in that dark room is where you have
to create
another human being that walks out of
that dark room
to face who you are
that's the only way you're going to get
over
all those things you have to create
someone else not like you have two
different personalities it is you
but you have to find strength and that
visualization of almost me
cracking out goggins like almost like
that superman cape like i'm coming out a
different person a person that doesn't
give a [ __ ] about anything who doesn't
care about being judged who knows i'm
weak who knows i'm afraid who says
whatever you think about me take it
whatever i'm here
that's goggins
in the dark room you face yourself you
realize you want to be better you
realize you don't want to be this weak
insecure person in the world he has all
these problems that we all have
we all have social media is a great
platform to tell you who we want to be
not who we are
so that's where that dark room is when i
say suffering people cringe
people that's the that's the one word
whenever i post about it
people cringe
it's not about suffering how people may
look at suffering like you have to just
go to a place that just every day of
your life is suffering
you have to tap into suffering every day
of your life because we have so much
scarring that we have to clean up
you have to look at suffering as almost
like i look at failure
to succeed you must fail
in failure and in suffering all the
answers are in there
all the answers to all the test
questions the test is your life
all the answers are in there you have to
live in suffering and pain and failure
all the time
you have to learn
i need to visit it like people hate
working out
you're only going to visit working out
maybe an hour a day
23 other hours of the day you're not in
it
but how you become in shape is you must
visit suffering visit working out one
hour a day visit suffering one hour a
day visit your past failures one hour a
day the relationship with it is the
answers are in there
they they are in there
within the suffering go in there
and i call it the live autopsy
the live autopsy how you find out
someone died they crack you open after
you're dead
how you can live is do it while you're
alive
go back in your brain crack it open
while you're alive don't wait until
you're dead to figure out why you died
do it while you are living
go in there go into the suffering go
into the pain of your life and say why
did this suck for me so bad
why am i afraid of all this stuff
why have i shut down the whole world
i guarantee i'll tell you why you shut
down the whole world it's in these nooks
of the suffering within your brain in
the scarring
are all the answers
to why you are on the couch feeling
sorry for yourself
they lie within the scars
visit them for at least an hour a day
study them
and then you'll find out more about
yourself you will then grow
so don't look at us every day i suffer
go into it an hour a day
learn from yourself learn from life
learn from your failures learn from your
insecurities learn from your self-doubt
don't just say i'm afraid to jump off an
airplane
what makes you afraid of it study it
that's why i studied my mind why i
became so powerful in the mind because i
realized i was weak
so instead of running away from the mind
i dove into and said what is making me
weak
oh
this makes sense
i came from hell
i came from a place that beat me down to
nothing
which is why i'm afraid
all this makes sense
so systematically one by one i went back
and met every single person in my mind
every situation
i went one-on-one with them again
in my mind i said okay
let's now revisit this and that's how
you do it that's how it works if you
want to know how david goggins takes
accountability for his life check out
the video right there next to me i think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
i'll see you there